it's gotten like 50 [ __ ] a hundred
thousand retweets is that what has
gotten by the way Chris loves this [ __ ]
he loves fighting with people online I
absolutely hate it he's serving grant
sandwiches all day great thought we just
did it was that what he said today
that's all he does this one has six
hundred twenty six thousand likes on it
this one has a hundred and forty
thousand retweets a hundred and forty
thousand retweets
so apparently Logan Paul said you can't
even it's so many people have commented
and liked on this Logan Paul wrote new
vlog end of the Logan pawpaw vlogs
important that you watch and then D'Elia
and I can hear it his voice just goes no
it's not that's it all he wrote quote
tweet no it's not and then Logan Paul
and this is you know a little bit
difference of me playing basketball
against Brucie when I was in in he was
st. Lawrence Logan Paul puts in two
hundred laughing crying tearing smiley
faces like laughing guy I'm laughing
because now I know why your comedy
career took a dive the problem with that
statement if you were a comic you'd know
this is that it's not true so when you
say something not true there's no joke
to it like no one laughs at it because
Chris's career is blowing up and it's
about to blow up ten times because you
don't know offense Logan Paul you don't
know how to do comedy so you're you're
taking your ego you're putting your ego
first and you're you're delivering your
ego into the slam you suck you you're
nobody well that's not that's not
accurate he's doing movies he's sells
out theaters like every night follow him
every time I'm in the store every night
I fall in the store it is a struggle
I've been doing comedy for twenty years
I'm a really good comic and Trust when I
tell you not one time do you go up
following D'Elia where you go like this
will be a cakewalk
every time you
kinda go like hey did he talk garlic
look you gotta you gotta be on your
[ __ ] guns when you follow Julia I do
it I do it every [ __ ] night I feel
like every [ __ ] night on behind alia
and so to say this is why your comedy
career took a dive you're just wrong
that's all that's all there is you're
just wrong and that's the basis of
comedy you can't go up on stage and go
all women are bad drivers you just not
that's why no one laughed no one laughed
because they go they're not that's you
instead of going along with you allowing
their their guard to be dropped and
moving forward I'm explaining this to
Logan Boggs apparently he doesn't
entirely get how Comedy Works instead of
like just going like shed the Cape here
we go I'm in tell me about it you said
the wrong thing it's just not true all
black people have webbed feet huh now I
can't follow you cuz I don't believe you
like it I can't believe anything this
guy says now I know why your comedy
career took a dive now I wish it were
there were exact times on that's 12:01
a.m. that he tweeted that Chris tweeted
his an hour later now that's a pro right
cuz he read his at 12:01 a.m. I
guarantee you Chris read it right away
he's up he doesn't drink
his girlfriend's beautiful they're
sitting there doing yoga blowing out
candles getting ready to go to bed and
Chris read that and he took his time
with it he probably fought like a couple
different things and he wrote at least
one Mike okay okay very well-crafted
I by the way I have to say this I
thought about this tweet and I would
tell it to people and I would rewrite it
in my brain the way I do comedy and it
never was as good as that you could film
it and put it on YouTube at least when
my career dies you can film it and put
it on YouTube slammed slammed good gunk
yeah by the way Logan Paul you're not
watching this I know you're not but if
you are dude get a guy props bring him
into your inner circle do a [ __ ]
video with him team up with a guy
[ __ ] like him because he's a [ __ ]
hilarious comedian and he slammed you
like legit
took you to the took you the hoop left
you in there in the [ __ ] there's more
oh what happened after this Logan Paul
goes both but not gonna lie this single
tweet is funner that funnier than your
entire Netflix special and Chris goes
Thanks
how does it feel to have your name
finally attach to something funny and
then Logan Paul goes 26,000 retweets
yeah Logan Paul goes I don't know what's
worse being the shunned vlogger or being
the 38 year old comedian arguing with a
shunned vlogger over Twitter and
crisco's ask your fans to have their
moms read this tweet out loud to them
see what they think
that's every single one of Logan Paul's
fans moms knows who crystally it's plus
if you went up to someone and go what's
worse being a Shanda vlogger or a 38
year old comic oh brother where do you
live
passing out I thought you just passed
out I thought I just passed out oh my
god we need to get you an oxygen tank
over there oh I thought I just passed
out I thought I just passed out